now I will turn it over to Bill Bernett
executive director of The Design Lab to
introduce today's
speaker thanks Annette that was
fantastic um I'm really excited to
introduce one of my colleagues in the
Design Group uh Monroe Kennedy is a
assistant professor of mechanical
engineering in the school of ing he also
has a courtesy appointment in computer
science he's the recipient of a National
Science Foundation career award given
you know to a very few number of people
for excellence in uh in engineering and
science research um he runs the
assistive Robotics and manipulation lab
we call us the arm lab which is a lab
dedicated to developing technology that
improves our everyday lives by creating
intelligent robotic systems that can
both perceive the our environments and
figure out uh what humans are doing in
these environments so that humans and
robots you know can uh work and live
side by side um monro's lab will be one
of the labs We Tour uh if you come to
the emerging technology um Workshop
that's coming up in March but we're
super excited to introduce him um he's
got a fantastic conver uh presentation
here on can machines understand human
intention can machines even understand
anything I guess is is an interesting
question and in in the world in in the
modern world of AI robotics autonomy and
other other kinds of robotic systems I
think this is really one of the most
interesting topics and then we're super
excited to we have a chance to bring it
to you um Monroe um why don't you to
take it
away all right thank you both for that
introduction um it's a pleasure to speak
with you today
uh so as mentioned um I direct the
assisted Robotics and manipulation
laboratory uh and one of the guiding
questions that we have is uh what comes
after robotic autonomy uh so if you
think about robotic autonomy that's the
ability for a robot um to be in an
environment to understand itself and its
task and be able to complete that
effectively uh but what comes next is
thinking about how that robot might need
to team with humans or other robots
uh and to do that effectively requires
modeling um those human
teammates um I have this figure here um
shown on the left that outlines how
collaborative robotics fits into this
larger conversation of robotic
autonomy so uh when you think about the
principles of robotic autonomy a robot
needs to be able to do three things it
needs to be able to see think and act um
formerly the that's perception how do
you observe the the world through a
camera through the sense of touch or
other mechanisms other sensors and
reduce this down to a state which is a
collection of variables that change and
based on observing their change you can
say something about how the world is
evolving and then given what you
observed uh in your environment how do
you plan on what you want to do next in
order to uh achieve some objective and
then how do you control how do you
actuate yourself how do you move how do
you uh provide some input that changes
the state of the world so that's the
cink ACT perception planning and control
uh in the larger context of how robots
might be teammates some of the
perception may include uh observing
humans in your environment so how do you
estimate their intent uh so something
that's very popular nowadays are
language models uh and that's a very um
uh uh adequate way to obtain intent from
those around you so perhaps I can speak
to my robot and say hey can you pick up
uh this cup of water on the table and
maybe that is a a valid form of input
but uh in my lab um and I think another
interesting question is when things have
to move very quickly it's sometimes not
always efficient to have to use
sentences to describe what you intend
and I would postulate to you that when
humans work together we also don't
always use language maybe we use it a
lot but we don't always use language um
to convey our intent and uh one of my
favorite examples is particularly in
sports so if you have people working
together uh in sports uh you know take
soccer or basketball they spend a lot of
time working together practicing uh so
they understand again how they want to
achieve their objective like scoring a
point but they're very familiar with the
abilities um and the signals that each
other are able to uh to convey and so
given the abilities of your teammate you
can exploit that to actually for
instance score a goal and so the ability
to understand your teammate to be able
to predict them to be able to read them
is crucial as a tactical Advantage um in
sports and this notion of how do you
estimate what your human teammate would
need if you're a robot is what we're
trying to capture and we need to express
that mathematically and that's what
we're going to get in today how do we
express that mathematically so I've I've
highlighted here on the left hand side
um uh three of these uh main points in
red which will touch on in more detail
the intent estimation how do I observe a
human and pull out a state that allows
me to estimate uh uh the variables that
are changing how do I use that state and
knowledge of the tasks that we're trying
to do together to predict how my actions
May influence the human and how their
actions May influence me uh and then
with that prediction how do I choose
what actions I should take that will
lead to um a better outcome for the
overall
team
so to start this conversation off um
we're going to build uh some tools first
we mentioned how do we need to
mathematically model uh the ability to
estimate intent um there are a few ways
to think about this um but the most
popular way right now uh is through
something called a generative model uh
this is not necessarily A New Concept
however some of the tools um that are uh
used to calculate it nowadays are very
hot uh and and uh very capable and to
start off here um I want to begin the
conversation with um a tool that most of
you are probably very familiar with uh
Chachi PT so um I'm sure we've all had a
chance to try this out you can go to
chat PT open aai uh you can put in a
prompt and you can get a very good um
personalized response um that most of
the time uh is pretty much on point um
with what you might have uh inputed um
as a as a query so here uh is an example
I've put in here how could humanoid
robots help Society what are the biggest
challenges for robots doing everyday
tasks uh and uh some of these answers I
completely agree with um highlighted
here on the right you know you can uh
provide assistance for those with
disabilities there's Healthcare
manufacturing manipulation and and
perception are the challenges uh did a
very good job um of of pulling uh that
answer very realistic you know on point
um beyond that you might see
applications uh for actual technical
assistance so let's say you have um a
wearable sensor uh where you want to use
an iPhone to do some sort of pose
tracking of a camera as you walk through
a particular space you can ask how you
might use um camera data from the Swift
which is the coding platform for Apple
to stream that to a computer that you
might connect with other robotic
components through Linux and Ross uh and
then you can see that this can give a
really good um uh output um that again
is typically about 80% correct so if you
kind of know this General coding
structure this can really get you moving
in the right direction quickly uh in
order to um begin implementing these
strategies and of course with uh gp4 you
have the ability to take a picture um of
some um website uh and or or input and
then it can actually take a picture a
rough idea and correlate this here to
ual HTML code um and other things like
this you can use images to also generate
text so uh what's going on under the
hood here and what are some domains for
this type of generative modeling um so
some of the examples I've given you just
now uh include text generation you put
some text into this model and text comes
out um diffusion image generation you
can put text in and an image may come
out uh and even um uh music you can put
in music signals and music uh will
actually come out with these different
um
tools but before we get into them even
more um I'd like to lay a very highlevel
quick mathematical foundation and I find
that this example here um is very uh
digestible so I would like to you know
um uh invoke your imagination uh imagine
you're a fisherman and you're trying to
determine uh where you should sail your
boat uh to find some fish and you uh
notice from past experience uh that it
might be helpful to determine uh where
the birds might be flying to actually
drive your ship to that relative
location so here on the left um we see
our Birds I'm going to call them an
event X the presence of the bir Birds
and the the the fish that are under the
water will call this variable y um and
our goal is to determine the
relationship between the fish under the
water and the birds that are in the air
so um uh please excuse the fact that
this is all on one slide uh but if you
go to the very top line here we have
this P of Y and this this upward line
and x uh and this is telling us uh what
is the probability that we will see the
fish given the presence of the birds and
we'll call this a posterior
probability um and we can find this if
we know a few things um statistically if
we can say from prior observations we've
seen uh in past past experiences that
when there were fish how often were
there Birds uh that will give us P of X
conditioned on why what is the
likelihood of birds given there were
fish and then if we have some
fundamental knowledge of the species so
what is the probability that the bird
species is going to be in this
geographical location given this time of
year have they migrated or or what's
their likely presence of being there
because there could be Fish And No Birds
simply because the birds have migrated
and likewise for the fish there could be
Birds but if the fish migratory patterns
uh are known then we can use that
knowledge as well and this leads us to
uh a very fundamental equation in
machine learning which is BAS theorem
where effectively we can use this prior
information about how uh birds and fish
relate um and the uh fundamental
knowledge of those species to then
calculate um this posterior probability
what is the likelihood of seeing uh fish
given there were Birds now I won't get
too mathematical on you but I wanted to
give this uh foundation so that you kind
of have a handle when we talk about
these tools and base theorem is
extremely powerful as is statistics
generally because it's the art of of of
effective
guessing another uh uh quick uh
intuition I want to give you here um is
this idea of do we expect a single
outcome or potentially a distribution of
outcomes so here on the on the left hand
side let's say we were we had a bucket
that was just sitting outside um and the
only way this could fill up is if there
was potentially rain uh so if there is
water in the bucket uh then we can um
assert that uh there was at least at
some point a cloud that filled it up
however uh on the other side if you look
on the right hand side of this image if
we see a dark cloud that potentially has
has rain and I were to ask you what is
the likelihood that this bucket is fill
uh filled or not uh well you have a
50-50 chance um has it begun to rain or
not um uh to fill this bucket up but
given this Cloud statistically in the
past you may have seen that this could
have 50 50% led to um some outcomes so
you have this distribution of outcomes
versus a single outcome that you can
infer um and a lot of machine learning
uh machine learning principles uh May
rely on one versus other paradigms of
thinking depending on what you're trying
to do so perhaps you're trying to learn
a relationship between variables where
you say if I had this outcome or this
variable x what is the likelihood that
this other thing happened that's a
regression model um but if I want to
realize that there are multiple things
that could come out of this a
distribution um that's this more
stochastic uh stochastic uh uh
representation that I might want to to
capture what you see here on the right
and both of those are useful depending
on your
task so to kind of again uh build some
idea of what an idea of the tools that
are actually used to do this in the wild
um I highlight these four types of
models uh one is a probabilistic
graphical model an autoencoder Model A
generative adversarial Network and
flow-based
models um the takeaway for these um that
I want you to have is there's this
variable X um shown usually in green
here or blue uh and then this variable Z
and what's Happening Here is this x is
some observation of the world um it
could be you know a camera image um or
some other data and you want your model
to understand the key features of what
uh that information um encodes and you
take uh an encoder model and you
compress it to this what we call latent
space um or the code and that's Z and
this is an efficient way for the
computer to think about some underlying
relationship and you use a decoder to
then say how do I go back to um some
representation of that state X Prime
where I've pulled out the key features
to understand um what was important um
how do I uh perform perform Salient
feature uh extraction here and so again
it's saying I'm giv raw data I compress
it to what's key and essential and then
I can decompress it um uh back to um
what was useful the big takeaways that I
wanted to have and so these are
different ways to do it um and we'll
talk about um some of these a little bit
in more detail but the goal is really to
just give you again some um some
knowledge of the jargon that's used in
this space to accomplish these types of
things so what's under the hood um so
the cha which we all know and love uh is
using called something called a
Transformer um and thinking back from
that last page there's three main
components there that are going inside
of it there's a variational encoder uh
recurrency which is allowing you to
perform a sequence prediction and then
attention which is telling you what's
the most important thing um in the
sequence of inputs that you should be
paying attention to so I first want to
bring your attention to this middle uh
uh uh image here I like science um and
the goal is to transform this into
German so you have an encoder that is
able to look over that sentence um
compress it into a code uh and then um
uh with a a a tag um output this um
translation in German uh that's the uh
sort of variational autoencoder
structure coming into play what's the
most important piece here how do I
compress it and then output it into this
other language where you would have the
decoder related to for instance German
or whatever other language you would
want recurrency says you know what kind
of sequence how does the past words
influence the future
um so you know the boy rode his bike to
the park is highly likely because of the
fact that you had those words in front
the boy rode his bike to had high
likelihood of a destination being an
outcome that's the recurrency attention
means maybe not every word that you was
spoken the boy rode his bike maybe just
boy Road and bike were the most
important things you needed to actually
infer what came next so attention says
what are the most important things in
the sequence I should pay attention to
to infer a particular
outcome another is this idea of
diffusion and so it says I can have a
relationship between a very crisp state
so here shown in this middle uh right X
knot and this relationship of
noise and the name of the game is to
think about how I could make this noise
these variables that are uh uh uh
positions that are random in position
how could I make them converge back to a
Salient state that actually makes sense
so he here you see this noise condensing
back to this s and the name of the game
here is if you think of all of these
points think of them kind of like sand
if you had like a sand Shaker how would
those sand shakers move back to their
relative positions that would actually
allow you to reconstruct an S and so the
modeling here says how should every
Point move along that space along the
plane to get back to its relative
position on the S and whatever you
condition on determines the shape of the
ground that would make that sand
particle move back to its position in
the S formation and that's what you
condition on so in this uh example for
text to image I say you know Pro produce
me a group of of uh robots playing the
violin and then given that as a text
input it then determines how to take a
noisy image and condens it back into a
Salient realistic looking image um that
captures what you conditioned on which
was the text and again there's this
latent structure that's coming into play
um that describes the gradient of how
those noise particles should conform to
give you back a Salient image um uh and
in this
form another example here uh is music
generation so same idea I can uh put in
a signal here um hear the beginning
notes of a song and then I can say you
know given all of the music I may have
exposed this model to what do you think
should come next and again um perhaps
elements um of uh you know features of
this song are being pulled out to
actually help you extract and
reconstruct similar um out uh um output
music so uh I think a very important
question here you know we see these
tools and we wonder um how powerful are
they right is this the dawn of you know
like true machine intelligence um and I
think these tools are very powerful very
useful um but I think a very important
thing we need to keep in mind um and
what may actually I think still
differentiate in some ways you know what
humans are able to do versus robot is
this idea of of original
thought um and so um I'll postulate this
example to you and then I'll I'll I'll
make it more high level and intuitive as
well so um again uh please excuse the
fact that everything's on the slide at
once but uh imagine I had um a sine wave
uh here so X is your input Y is the
height of the wave um and the blue
region you see here is all you
originally expose your model to so um
over this span of 20 points the sine
wave uh doesn't drastically increase um
in its magnitude it's increasing fairly
slowly um so you know it would be a
perfectly Fair assumption to assume in
the blue region that all you would need
to predict the Y um is just sign of
X however um clearly we can know with
our you know external view here uh that
uh that's not a complete uh view of how
this model um would behave and in fact
um it would be better um to actually be
able to extract further to have
something that would predict um points
that are far outside of the region you
were trained in um and so this is the
challenge right how do you say you know
if I expose my chat model to a bunch of
verbal examples the internet as it
exists today and I go create something
new it can interpolate what currently
exists but if I say create something
brand new um it won't be able to do that
so the very easy example I put here in
the bottom right is if I asked my uh
chat GPT prompt you know what's a
compact or portable Fusion reactor
design
uh it'll throw its hands up and say I
don't know now does that mean that this
is unknowable knowledge I don't believe
so uh we can look at like Lawrence
Livermore and the advances that they
have I'm confident in the next few
decades we will see a solution here so
if there's if all of the knowledge to do
this currently is existing or being
built or could be built up by us why
can't chat GPT do this yet and it's
because it's interpolating from what
currently exists and it's not extract
stating beyond the training set beyond
what it was exposed
to so how would we achieve that um what
are some high level thoughts that it
would take to actually do that well you
know to achieve this you have to be
somewhat self-aware and say well uh even
in the region that I'm exposed to um how
do I make sure that I'm doing a really
good job of explaining that behavior
everywhere and maybe for some parts that
are really far away if I could gain
access to those components could I make
my model uh actually uh perform
correctly and predict those things that
are very far away um I have a passion
for physics so I love to use this
particular physics example um how you
know even aspects that um physicists are
able to do to uh explain uh you know
features very far away like you know a
few years ago we were able to get our
first picture of a black hole it took
the entire planet coming together to
effectively create a camera that
literally spanned the planet to get this
picture of a black hole and the
equations that described this were those
that described things on a smaller and
smaller level so we go from Newton to
Einstein to even smaller uh uh equations
that are more compact that as we
understand our universe in a more
fundamental way actually extend and
allow us to make predictions that are
even further away like a black hole I
use that as analogy here uh if I were to
look at this sign function and I were to
say Okay I want to have a description
that is accurate everywhere I need to um
be able to model the most compact form
of this uh of this equation and have it
be applicable have it be accurate even
far outside of domain as well as within
domain and so uh I believe the the path
forward for that is actually models that
understand
contextualization and are able to
modularize their components and play
them out and understand how they would
affect each other how they would behave
even far outside of the the domain they
were originally exposed to which is I
would argue how we conceptualize things
we think about Concepts we form
hypothesis by saying how these Concepts
should play together and then we test
them that's the scientific
process so um changing gears a little
bit here how should we uh what should we
consider uh when constructing a model so
here I've I've drawn a simple uh
pendulum on a string here where the
pendulum uh has some mass and it's
moving mov back and forth it makes some
angle Theta with the uh ceiling um and
you can think of the state the most
efficient way to represent the uh
changing variables of this uh pendulum
as the angle and the angular
velocity if I have a camera that's
looking headon at this pendulum as it
swings I could try to extract the state
um from this image and so the key uh uh
relationships that I need to be aware of
here uh include the observation so if x
is my image this is what I'm observing
and I'm trying to um U predict uh and
understand that relationship I can say
how is my image uh dependent on um the
current state the Theta Theta Dot and if
there's any actuation if I have a motor
or something that's uh forcing some
motion uh causing some action how is my
output image related to those variables
I can talk about the Dynamics how do
things change how do I expect the uh
position and uh velocity of this
pendulum to change conditioned on the
past position um in any action that was
taken if there is a decision maker
that's changing the state of my system
what's driving their actions and this is
in the machine learning uh Community
known as a policy um in the like
analytical controls area this is um a
controller description and so um I
represent these in a probabilistic
framework because it's a sort of
catchall framework whether you're
dealing with analytical equations or
even um different types of
representations and so this often falls
into something called um a Markoff
decision process or a partially
observable Markoff decision process
which describes how a state changes and
everything that uh May contribute to
that change of state and how you might
observe
it the other key uh thing here is when
you begin to try and think about
distributions of outcomes um you
literally have a statistical
representation here like a gauen and so
if I have this uh shown in the middle
here some P of theta which represents my
models distribution and I had some
training data that I exposed you to uh
which is this green uh cue of sigh um
the goal is to match these distributions
and again let me ground this for you um
imagine um I have uh a person that's
driving around a track and I want to do
a a physical Turing test um I want you
to if if you're in the stands I want you
to tell me if a person is driving that
car or if a machine is driving that car
um how would you determine that well
perhaps if you watch the person um
they're super efficient at this they do
some drifting but you notice that their
motion is not exactly perfect while
they're fast the motion that they they
perform is not exactly perfect whereas
perhaps if I showed you a machine
driving around the track it would
actually look like it was flying by a
wire perfect execution every time and
that's how you would determine that a
car or an Optimus vehicle was actually
driving on that side so if I wanted to
fool you the task I would have would be
to add enough noise to the behavior of
the car so that it would mimic that of a
human so you couldn't differentiate
between the two and so this is just an
example showing how distribution itself
can be useful for
um mimicking um aspects of
behavior so uh with that um I'd like to
kind of move into uh more specifically
this idea of teammate prediction and
then tie this into some of the work
that's uh currently being done in my
research
lab so some questions we might have when
you think about um robots and humans um
working together is how do they
conceptualize each other so here uh in
this cartoon in the center I've drawn
drawn this image of a robot thinking
about the team um and it even has a
little thought Cloud for the human um
this is formerly known in my field as uh
uh u a theory of Mind of the first and
second order the first order says I just
conceptualize uh myself and my teammate
second order says I'm also trying to
think about what my teammate is thinking
about and use that to help me make
decisions and plans so um here are four
big questions you might ask yourself in
this space you know do agents share the
same goals and and objectives who if
anyone is in charge in the team if the
robot is predicting multiple partners um
and their future actions how can this be
done efficiently and where does task
domain knowledge come from where did you
learn to do the thing we're asking you
to
do again our trusted tools come back to
play uh here we see the conditional
variational autoencoder uh generative
adversarial networks flow-based models
all of these uh can be useful tools
among others um but these are very
popular right now uh all of these can be
very useful tools to try and infer and
predict human behavior given the
exposure to their past Behavior as your
training data so I watch a human do
something for some period of time I
collect these observations and then I'm
trying to statistically match that
distribution so that my robot can
predict um with some likelihood what
might happen next realizing that
teammates are stochastic so we don't
expect to get perfectly right every time
but we want it to be very close within
distribution of what uh the teammate
might
do uh this uh provides a very um a nice
description too of how this might work
um in a formal framework so here you
have this robot and human team they
share a mutual goal and objective they
both are able to take actions on the
world or the task this cause this causes
the task uh to change um and we can
measure this in terms of some sort of
State Evolution the agents um human and
robot would observe that change and that
would help them infer what what future
actions they should take and we're
postulating here that if the robot is
able to conceptualize all of these
components the
objective the policies for both agents
how the task will evolve and how both
agents will perceive the world then the
robot has a chance of rolling these
things out um in the future in its mind
and saying how does this maximize some
measure of benefit or reward and then I
can then say if I think of this stoas
stochastically I could look at many
different sequence of action Pairs and
then determine uh what action I should
take next that maximizes some potential
output allowing me to be a better
teammate uh with the
human so now I I'll quickly show you a
few examples uh in my lab that
demonstrate this um I have a few videos
um that won't play through these slides
but if you go to my website arm.
stanford.edu under research you can
actually see some very cool videos for
all the things that I'm telling you uh
right
now so um in this domain um this first
problem we had was thinking about how a
robot could substitute um and serve as a
teammate alongside a human so um the
concept is shown here on the left so we
have this robot that ultimately wants to
help carry a table with the human um and
what it does is in this subth thought
Cloud you see this ax
it's able to observe two humans work
together so we expose it to data where
humans work together
extensively and from that it says okay
I'm in a very similar situation to what
I saw two humans in what would a human
do and it uses those statistical models
we discussed to understand all of the
possibilities that it was exposed to
given a similar placement that it's
experiencing and after planning and
looking at all of those potential
outcomes in uh part C it can say this is
going to be the outcome I'm going to
pursue most because I think it will
maximize my reward of getting close to
the goal quickly without striking one of
these red obstacles uh shown here on the
right um is the uh methodology um by
which my uh graduate student eling
achieved this uh so here the observation
buffer is all of the human human data
that we collected where humans played
this game together in a simulator uh we
then compress this into a variational
current neural network which outputs
motion predictions expected paths that
are similar to what humans demonstrated
for us we then select what we believe to
be the optimal path given the distance
traveled and other parameters and then
uh we tell our robot to execute that
path alongside a human um and we observe
the outcome um of that uh shared
trajectory and so um we showed in our
work that if you compare this to um RR
uh which is a way of saying let me just
explore random paths and try to make
sure none of those random paths I roll
out don't hit any obstacles and
eventually reach my goal compared to
this method that's informed by what
humans demonstrated for you we're able
to show um that um the vrn um our method
actually produces much smoother outcome
paths um in the
end additionally um you might say when
you're doing this task uh maybe you
followed uh um an efficient path but how
do you know necessarily um that they
were more collaborative than if they
were to pick random paths that didn't
necessarily hit an object one way to
think about this is through something
called interaction forces and so if you
were playing tug-of-war tug of-war is
literally a game of inducing stress in a
rope because there's disagreement one
team wants to pull the Rope to one side
the other wants to pull the team to the
the Rope to the other side there's these
really large tension forces inside side
of a rope in the game of tug of-war um
however if I were to pick up an object
in my hand um perhaps I am applying some
forces just to localize it but I might
not be squeezing this with all of my
strength because there's agreement
between my fingers on how I actually
want to move this object so uh one
measure that the field has agreed upon
is this notion of interaction forces how
much stress or compression are you
applying to the object you're carrying
um and how can that be used as a measure
to measure consensus between the agents
involved and so what you see is um if
you have two humans carrying something
together the interaction forces are low
they're not zero but they're low and um
if you use our vnn they're also pretty
low if you don't and you use the sort of
random path planner that shouldn't
Collide um you'll see that these
interaction forces the tug of war is
quite high it was hard for the robot and
human to reach consensus
another really cool aspect here um is
this notion of the Turing test so we did
this experiment where we said okay we're
going to set up a barrier and we're
going to have a participant uh work with
um this simulated uh partner in the
carrying task and we're going to have
them do a bunch of Trials and in some of
them they're going to be working with a
robot in others they're going to be
working with a human and we want to know
if they're able to correctly identify
who they're working with based on the
behavior that they experienced as they
played the game um and so what you see
here on the bottom right are the results
from that exper experiment blue is the
sort of random um uh path generator
which we don't expect to succeed very
well and vnn was our method that was
informed by watching humans work
together and um this uh xaxis um gives
you um what the human thought versus
what it actually was so if they thought
it was a human and it was a human they
got that correct if they thought it was
a robot R given that it was a robot SLR
then it was correct and what we saw was
with our method we actually did a decent
job of confusing people um when uh we
actually um had uh the vrn system and
this is just a violin plot so this says
all the data that we took what's the
distribution of that um in case it
wasn't unimodal um and you'd like to see
the true
distribution um my student extended this
work and I encourage you to again check
out her really cool video where we
actually said now what if we used an
even more advanced uh method to en
capture and Model Behavior um and so for
that we used a diffusion co- policy and
it turns out that when we expose this
diffusion co-p policy to uh examples of
human data and then we transported that
to the robot the robot began to exhibit
um very interesting highlevel behaviors
um in particular some that you'll see in
her video includ includes the ability to
serve as a leader and then transition to
a pivot to then become a follower so
that the uh table could efficiently
navigate um the obstacles and when we
saw that that made us very
excited another project I'll quickly
mention um uh in this space uh uses the
same type of tools but applies it to a
completely different domain um and
that's the intelligent prosthetic arm so
in this instance imagine you know
someone has had a shoulder
disarticulation so they don't have their
entire arm and we want to endow them
with either a prosthetic arm or a
teleoperated arm so that they can do
complex manipulation tasks again there's
two ways to think about this one where
you say well we know all the tasks they
might want to do like drinking from cups
picking up a fork and then there could
be an instance where you need to teach
them how to do a novel thing how do I
teach you how to um how to move the hand
in order to complete a task and it turns
out that this same type of framework
where you say given um the tasks that
are uh there how do I extract their
intent from their gaze if I have them
wearing a headset what are they looking
at I could use EEG intracortical to
understand their brain wavs how that
might give me an idea of what they want
to engage with their EMG so mus any
muscle actuation they're able to provide
how can I condition on all of these
inputs be them Limited in order to
control um a high degree of freedom um
uh uh
arm another I'll mention to you is this
fall prevention wearable sensor um so in
this domain uh we think about uh
particularly uh what might lead to
imbalance um in a person and it turns
out that this is um actually a leading
cause of fatal and non-fatal injuries in
older adults those were 65 and older um
and the question we had is realizing
that uh Falls can be C can be caused by
internal things like like illness and
psychological factors but they can also
be caused by external things so if they
bump into something or something bumps
into them um we're saying well what we
can do right now is think about those
external factors and particularly how
they're walking in an environment so a
passive perturbation you're tripping
over some steps you're bumping into a
wall um or something can we understand
given how you've walked and watching a
whole bunch of people walk can we
predict how there are features in your
environment that might potentially lead
to um
imbalance and so my student um he made
this initial wearable sensor that's able
to uh includes a camera that's mounted
on your torso um Imus that are located
on your legs and the idea here uh is
that using these he can observe the
environment um in order to use a machine
learning model to accomplish
this so now we're back to our problem
statement and while we'll use some fancy
models to accomplish this it's very
useful to formally say what our state is
and we can represent our objectives in a
probabilistic manner so here our state
includes what's the pose of the person
where are they in space what's the
velocity of their torso if their uh
motion of their torso if they have some
natural Sway and Cadence can we actually
predict that sway that Cadence um and
then um monitor that change in case that
might inform us about potential
imbalance can we watch uh their step
frequency and the joint angles in their
legs and so these two probabilistic
statements says um given how they've
walked so far and the environment can we
predict where you're going to walk in
the future and given what we've seen so
far and where you've walked can we
predict how the environment will change
around
you so the first challenge we had um for
this was how to represent the
environment in a way that a neural
network could digest and use for
prediction so for our first step for
that we use this uh sensor that was
mounted on the Torso to collect images
and depth images um from our
surroundings and what we did was we
created a panorama so if you see this
person in the middle of the screen at
the bottom there's this cylinder that
encapsulates them you can think of this
as a a cylindrical image where the red
line can be cut and opened up so that it
becomes a rectangular image you see in
the top right hand side so whatever is
right in front of you is a small area
right in the center of that image which
you see as the second row image on the
right and if you're walking Straight
Ahead um then that's the red path um
drawn in this image where your feet are
at the bottom of the image and then you
would walk up in front of you based on
what you're able to see and so this was
a way that we could actually efficiently
represent the uh obstacles around us um
uh in order to um uh provide that
information to our
model the other thing was this notion of
Sway covariance and so by watching the
motion of our torso we learned um that
in fact uh when someone is perturbated
um if you watch the statistics of how
there if you had a a z-axis pointing up
straight up and you projected into the
ground plane um there's going to be some
natural uh motion that makes this sort
of ellipse this covariance if someone's
perturbated this ellipse grows very
sharply and that growth can be useful
for predicting that something caused
perturbation and perhaps that might be
uh something that would cause you to
fall so this is our machine learning
model um that we ultimately ended up
using to perform this prediction um so
don't get overwhelmed by the details
I'll highlight what's important so we
have the images um uh which created the
depth image for our surroundings as an
input it went through this Auto encoder
and was represented in a latent space
that was a way for the network to
efficiently model what was important in
the environment as you walked through
that environment and and then we had our
state we had the odometry where you were
walking and Joint angles and we went in
through this lstm our long short-term
memory which is one of those recurrent
networks so it said given everything
that has happened up until now how can I
predict the next few sequences of what
will happen conditioned on the past uh
and then using this It produced how it
expected your walking to evolve and how
it expected your uh environment or your
latent state to evolve as well and so we
walked into different places around
campus um and we collected measures for
uh a a prediction Horizon of 7 seconds
on how well um we could actually predict
where you would end up um and so what we
learned is if you were indoors where it
was kind of like tighter regions it was
actually um uh really good to predict
within about two meters where you would
end up so uh in these drawings the red
line is the average line the solid line
is the average line and then the color
shaded area is the co variance
associated with this so the top row is
indoor the second row is um outdoor
cluttered and the third row is outdoor
free and so what uh the point I really
want to drive home here is we could do a
decent job of predicting where the
person would go but there was this
variance and this variance doesn't
necessarily mean our model was wrong it
just means that perhaps there were many
solutions that ultimately would occur
and if we only predicted one um we may
not exactly be correct because there's
this distribution that a person may walk
that all would be valid
choices a really cool feature and I
encourage you again go check out this
video um was actually the fact that we
could do a decent job of predicting
behavior in environments so here is a
picture inside of our psychology
building and um with these sets of
images you'll notice on either side of
the dash line there's on the top row a
vision model and a no vision model um
for time segments A B C D E and F um if
you look at the r for vision model the
blue line and its ellipses represent
where you walked in the past and the
suway covariant at those instances the
green line uh represents where you
actually ended up because we recorded
all of that data um and we then
post-processed it to to uh to do it when
we then validated it and the red line
with its ellipses indicate where you
predicted you would end up um and where
you how you predicted the suway
covariance of the person and what you'll
notice is if you don't use Vision um the
model just assumes inertia it assumes if
you're walking in a particular way
you're going to keep walking because
that's all it has access to but if you
incorporate conditioning on the
environment and pass data of people
walking it begins to learn that it can't
walk into walls um that there's
likelihood of you turning down uh
walkways when it's available and then
given how you're orienting your body you
may walk in a particular way and given
your speed You can predict how fast
you'll walk in the future as
well another really cool feature here
was as you walk in particular
environments there was actually a
correlation in your sway covariant um as
you walked in those zones so here's a
picture of my uh graduate student he's
walking around campus uh and what was
interesting was when he took sharp turns
his sway covariant turned uh changed in
a particular way and after being exposed
to that type of data uh the model was
actually able to to predict the motion
of his torso given the path that he was
going to
walk um and so again these are some
really cool videos I encourage you to
check out you can actually see in real
time that motion of the Torso as well as
the uh sway covariant as they walk
through an environment some future
directions for this well we have that
covariance that wasn't perfect so what
if we wanted to predict multiple
trajectories and uh perhaps the sensor
system that we showed you is not cool
enough for people people to wear uh it
would be better if it could perhaps be a
smartphone uh and then down the line
we'd like to also actually help
populations that could use this so this
could be older populations or people
with neurological disabilities could you
outfit with them with this sensor
collect their data and then make this
system work for them and perhaps use
this also in lower limb exoskeleton
control which my lab is excited to
collaborate with Professor Steve Collins
here in the mechanical engineering
department at Stanford as
well so we've implemented this on a
smartphone we're actually able to get
really good uh depth representation data
um my student is also trying to improve
the ability to estimate sway covariants
um we have this software called 4D
humans that's able to extract the pose
of the person um and then we can
actually monitor their sway as they walk
and then we can actually collect videos
from the wild where we see instances
where people fall and we can learn if
our parameter is actually useful in
predicting whether those Falls might
occur
and finally we're able to say well uh
given the fact that we might want to
predict multiple paths and environments
we can use diffusion models to actually
predict those uh multiple hypothesis
paths so here we use a segment anything
framework from Facebook to actually
partition uh doors walls obstacles
ground and then with this watch the data
where people walked and then predict
multiple hypothesis of where they may
end up so here you see two distributions
of paths some that lead through this
doorway others that make a turn and both
of those are um actually uh valuable
outcomes so the takeaway I want to leave
you with today um Is that real world
user human data can serve as a strong
prior for teammate prediction through
generative modeling and the ability to
predict the teammate can lead to more
effective collaboration and I will end
with that thank you very
much I S Monroe thanks so much this is
really interesting and a very insightful
presentation you and your lab are doing
some really great work and um it was
really great to to have you share that
with with the audience today um now
let's get into some questions Bill did
you want to kick us off um and then I
will take a look at what we have in the
Q&A well we've got you know we have a
limited amount of time so I think I'll
just I'll have one question but let's
let's jump into the Q&A uh Monroe you
mentioned some things about you know
fall detection or um folks who have
disabilities can you talk a little bit
more about what your lab was doing um
with these predictive models that might
be useful for folks that have either
limited Mobility or other or other um
disabilities yeah um so two of the ones
that I mentioned today particularly um
included like the intelligent prosthetic
arm um and the other like the fall
prevention sensor which you just
mentioned um I think in both cases the
question that we're asking is one of
intention estimation right there either
in the case of the intelligent
prosthetic the person does not have an
ability and we want to endow them with
that uh ability but they have the uh the
ability to give us some sort of input um
but if you're trying to control these
systems the like the degrees of freedom
that you need to control are so high and
complex uh that it's very difficult to
extract that low-level control from the
person so we can bring robotic autonomy
where a robot knows how to do a task um
and then couple that with ever ways of
reading the person right estimating
their intent then we can uh uh return
hopefully some of that ability some of
that Agency for them to do particular
tasks and in the case of of of the
fallaw prevention sensor this is
augmentation so we assume that the
person is capable but they could use
some help to avoid some unfortunate
outcomes and this could again be in fall
prevention or in like exoskeleton
control the idea here is you may not
necessarily be replacing their ability
um but your ability to predict and
assess and predict risk um becomes
useful in protecting or helping these
individuals it's just it's just
fantastic and you know the I I have a
sense from your talk that we're right on
the edge of some amazing you know new uh
capabilities NE to augment you know um
human capabilities or to replace things
that for whatever reason age or or
disease or something has caused us to
have a disability
um Anette do you have some questions
from the from the audience I'm sure they
are full of questions I do there there
are a ton so um I will'll try to get as
many as we can but for for to kick us
off um Professor Monroe as we progress
towards machines understanding human
intention what potential positive and
negative impacts could this have on
society and how can we ensure
responsible and ethical development in
this
domain it's a great question um you know
I would start off with with the sort of
positive by really just emphasizing need
um I think to date many times you know
the conversation with robotics and
robotic autonomy is concern around
replacement um but the goal of Robotics
is to improve human life um and so that
doesn't always necessarily mean a robot
replacing a particular task if the task
is very dangerous for people and people
are getting hurt or they're being
mistreated then perhaps a robot should
be replacing those instances um but if
that's not the case then maybe
augmentation is the answer how do we
make people more efficient um and so I
think you know thinking about uh
examples in Assisted Living you know you
could have robots that could work with
um people who want to live in their
house longer um maybe they have small
issues with dexterity and other things
but they're uh cognitively all there and
you know they could hopefully live on
their own a little bit longer with the
Aging population worldwide having these
types of systems that could help in that
way would be
extremely helpful um and you can think
of uh other instances in
agriculture um in terms of like you know
helping with sustainable Foods having
robots that could uh work along Farmers
to achieve those things uh you could
think of the elderly population as I
mentioned manufacturing making sure
that's Humane effective while you know
not necessarily diminishing output um
are all very good uh potential um
outcomes um you know I think with as
with every engineering tool um ethics is
important and there are ways that these
things could be potentially abused or
misused um one that immediately comes to
mind you know is um you know I think at
some point we want to make sure that
these Solutions are democratized they
should be accessible to everybody and so
um it would be great to say you know I
have this robot that has all of these
capabilities I would love to say if I
put this robot in an old older person's
home maybe there's a flat rate uh that
they have for this um and there should
be a level of functionality that they
should not be nickel and dimed for you
know oh my robot can make tea so you
have to pay you know a subscription fee
of $10 a month if you wanted to make tea
for you it if it knows how to make tea
it should make the person tea I think
you know not uh making sure that the
fundamental skills of these systems are
democratized so that there's
accessibility and usability and that we
you know stay on track for net positive
effort um again I think you know these
tools are very powerful you know even
more fundamentally than the robotss the
power of prediction is itself a very
incredible thing we predict the weather
and it leads to you know um us being
able to protect ourselves right um but
everything you know again has the
ability to be misused so I think there
is an idea of you know fundamentally
thinking right you know it is our
responsibility to make sure that the
solutions we develop are helping people
and not harming them um and at some
level you know with every powerful tool
it does become on the honest of the
developer to make sure that they're um
being used in responsible ways and
Society to hold people accountable when
they're
not yeah that's great um thank you so
much for those insights um I think we
have time for about one more question so
um I know you touched on this a little
bit in the presentation but one of our
participants is interested in in kind of
expanding more around what role does
artificial intelligence and machine
learning play in advancing the field of
human robot interaction specifically and
enabling machines to understand and
adapt to diverse human
intentions that's a great question so um
you know I think machine learning has
again played this really fundamental
role of um allowing us to model
stochastic processes right um you know
if you put an input in and you expect a
single output that's an analytical
description that can be very useful for
things where the rules are very defined
um but you know data science is becoming
very popular because the real world is
often very hard to model um and also
very noisy um however there's a a
significant power of Statistics right to
be able to understand the distribution
of particular outcomes and uh machine
learning and AI is that tool that sits
on those statistical principles in order
to allow us to predict those events with
high likelihood um I think with that
ability of prediction with that ability
to model things that are not analytical
we will see robots that are able to
adapt to uncertainty in their
environment to adapt to variability that
exists um and with this ability to adapt
um we'll see their utility spike in a
very significant way and with that I
think we'll see just Improvement in
human life as these physical embodied
intelligence systems are able to improve
the world we live in yeah a very
interesting time um in in life and I am
very exciting so thank you again so much
Professor Monroe this is this was really
interesting and insightful loved the
conversation to everyone in the audience
with us live today thank you for your
questions and your participation I want
to remind you that today's session was
recorded and a link will be sent out to
you within a week um please have a great
rest of your day and I'll see everyone
next
time